love to talk about gen zeroes a little
bit
um you're on this upcoming program not
just as an actor but as a producer can
you tell me sort of the full range of
your involvement with this
it's more than a program really yeah
it's more than a program it's it's it
started out as an opportunity to work
with alex bonovic who's a
a good buddy of mine we've done some
other projects together he played my
brother you know a movie i did vendetta
that was directed by the social sisters
um
we've done some stuff on psych um
we just hit up a really good friendship
immediately hanging out and um i did van
helsing with him he called me up and
says hey we kind of got this part on van
gaal saying we don't know if we can
afford it i'll do it i get to hang out
with you
and he was blown away and it's like
for me at this stage of the game i'm
just into having fun and working with
people that i want to work with i like
it's it's a fun
skill set to work on i like entertaining
people
i'm lucky that i don't
i don't have to pay the bills on my
acting skills thank god
[Laughter]
i'm lucky that way but my heart my heart
really goes out too and i really
emphasize with real professional actors
that are doing this grind and taking
rejection and doing the reads and
getting turned down so for this with gen
zeros
you know
i got the script and uh just the just
the overall what we wanted to do with it
and um
matt and jeremy just gave me so much
freedom of this character
this thatched character in the setting
and i was like i mean i i get to have
this much fun with it yeah i'm in
and then you know as it was developing
and we were putting stuff together they
were explaining on the nfts to me and
the involvement of building a community
and the idea of
uh the community being able to have some
influence you know with the nfts and
their their coin uh usage to
just for like even determine some of the
outcomes of some of the story plots of
the characters like you know remember
the old books you could choose your own
ending there's gonna you know there's a
lot of opportunities with gen zero
unlike anything i've ever seen in any
series before for community involvement
and
after so many years four decades of
pro wrestling and wearing spandex for a
living i understand that your audience
and your community is more important
than anything that you can do
so this project really gives that
opportunity for for science fiction fans
to get involved and also
get way ahead on the collectibles market
because you know we all know
if we didn't know where star wars was
going when it came out probably came out
before your time but it was relatively
i'm you'd be surprised how big of a
fantastic
well um
no one knew how big that was going to be
us as kids and when star wars came out
we were blown away by it i mean i think
the first two movies i saw in the movie
theater
were
the black hole i don't know if you
remember that movie it was a really
scary science fiction movie for like a
six-year-old the evil robot was
maximilian i had nightmares over that
that's my mother's fault because she's a
science fiction oh you'll survive you'll
be fine meanwhile i'm having night
terrors and then star wars is one that
we really got behind and enjoyed it as
kids and now gen zero's just with the
stuff that they're doing and uh and i
read a lot of science fiction now i'm a
big fantasy fan so
seeing an opportunity to be a part of
this
how can i not say that i mean this is
one of those kind of things that's like
uh you know i'm not in this that's uh
you know to to get rich or to
uh buy a home in hawaii or some kind of
nonsense like that this is a really
great project that i'm working with a
lot of friends a lot of people that have
donated a lot of time and a lot of
skills
and they're building a community for
people to get involved with and that's a
good thing to be a part of i've seen you
in the past plummet off a rooftop 1995
halloween havoc and you're you're
talking to me here today can you walk me
through this match you had with hulk
hogan after which um he shoved you off
the roof like what how was it actually
set up how did this come together well
are you okay yeah i'm okay but uh i'm i
definitely wouldn't even consider doing
that now at my age that
my wisdom like no why are we doing that
but at 22 23 years old i'm like yeah
whatever you want to do it's great push
about the building awesome you know
because you're just so excited you know
um
that night i remember it was in detroit
and it was so
cold it was halloween havoc
um
and it was in october in 1995 and it was
so cold we were on the roof we did the
monster truck battle
because that was a
uh a thing that we did i ran over
hogan's motorcycle my monster truck that
when he went and got a monster truck and
then we had a
a monster truck duel that i lost
and then we got out and fought around
and then the thing was for me to
[ __ ] off the building
and uh you know it was about four
stories into a big air bag i'm not a
stunt man i've never
done anything like that you know but
you know we had our skunk we're all it's
this big airbag it's fine don't worry
about it
and uh so you're young and you think
you're bulletproof you just you know
okay sure we go off it
and uh then we went and had the match i
remember asking kevin sullivan who was
kind of
in charge of the creative or what back
then we called him a booker
i said hey kevin should i be like you
know like bruised up or anything from
fallen because i don't know i'm so green
like you know he goes
rada get a giant you're fine he walked
off
so that was the old halloween havoc i
just remember being extremely cold
that night filming it like freezing
because we had those little race
thermal suits in case the engine caught
on fire or something like fire protected
suits that we had to wear
but still it was like super because i
have my wrestling gear on underneath of
it which if you know
isn't much
i got like one straw i got one uh one
boob hanging out basically
and uh
they
how what was your like and what was your
reaction the moment of the fall because
candidly the camera angle doesn't do it
justice it doesn't it doesn't do it
justice my reaction was i've said this
before as a joke but
uh just being young and being funny when
i went over and hulk's looking over the
top and i was flipping my bird on the
way down
you know it's a wonder he didn't bust
out laughing when i did it because i
kind of saw his face
you know but uh that was that was the
fun days of wrestling when we were
we were doing that crazy uh
crazy off the mark kind of stuff there
is this urban legend involving you i'm
not sure if you're familiar with this
and and don't worry you're not gonna end
up on dark side of the ring
we're
okay
uh
allegedly in your youth the wcw power
plant when you're first sort of getting
your uh rounds in as a professional
wrestler you performed a moonsault now
yes is this true because no one everyone
people have said they've seen the video
no one can produce the video no it's
probably gone by now it's probably like
i mean that was done probably with
vhs tape
so long ago that hung around the
training room because nobody like
it was one of the things that passed
around who knows it probably got
it's probably in a landfill somewhere in
georgia by now but uh
um
i was able i had athleticism that was
crazy for someone my size when i came
and i could do kick ups i could do drop
the extra kicks off the top to do a
moonsault
um but i was
believe or not the way the industry then
because it was still transiting um
nobody knew really what to do with me
because i was like anything i've never
seen before so they want some guys
wanted me to wrestle like andre well
andre
worked a different style in a different
area to me when i worked like andre it
felt like you know it was a snooze fest
you know so it was hard to find out how
do i show that i'm an athlete how do i
there were so many things that as a
business change i had to learn and
develop and change over the years but uh
yeah all that was uh legit stuff i took
a perfect flex from kurt henning and
then did a kickoff i think that's on
that i actually did on raw so that
that's somewhere on the internet but all
of that stuff was
i used to be able to kick a 6 8 door
frame too
stand in side kick i would
flex up and kick the top of the door
frame did the moonsault ever make it to
a match or strictly in front of a
strickland training no no no in japan
there are rumors of me doing it in japan
and uh it wasn't yeah it wasn't a match
it was screwing around the afternoon and
then i was told immediately not to do it
ever again if i wanted to continue
working where i was
because i was thinking well japan is a
great place to break it out here we'll
go
and uh i it was it was shut down
immediately by those that uh had the
greater control freddy prince jr uh
recently mentioned that kieran culkin
fantastic actor huge wrestling fan once
threw a beer at you at a live event do
you have any memory of this no but it's
okay
you know i mean i i've been hit with
beers i've been hit with
there was a there was a lady in memphis
an older lady in memphis that used to
carry a
uh like a heavy object in her purse if
you're a bad guy she hit you in the back
with it if you got too close to her so
the thing was if you
if you didn't
if you were new the old guys wouldn't
smarten you up but they would position
the mat so oh yeah right here you know
if you roll out to the floor here just
be in this corner and we'll do something
and then you're right in front of the
the you know and the lady was like you
know she was like a fan favorite like
everybody knew what she was gonna do so
everybody was in on the spot except for
you and you're the guy getting hit so
but you know that's you know it's i
think you've done your job
back then if
people were emotionally invested i
remember doing a class once with i think
it was flare and i against hogan and
savage in vegas
and somebody threw a 9-volt battery
and the battery hit me right in the top
of the head as uh
hogan or savage was coming out
and i mean man it stung i knew like tv
was on i didn't want to rub my head and
draw attention to it i was trying to man
up but my eyes were watering so that i
looked at jimmy hart i said i just got
hit head with a battery and jimmy hart
pats my arm he goes it's okay baby
you're all right it's okay
speaking of being a good guy and a bad
guy uh you have transitioned a lot many
times between i've had more turns there
in nascar i've heard it said i i saw a
youtube video today allegedly between
1995 and 2020 there were 37. that's
about right do you have one that sticks
out the most is your favorite turn from
good guy to bad guy or bad guy to good
um
probably
trying to think
big turns like that i've always i always
did a lot of turns at the draft where i
would leave one brand and turn to
another brand it's a lot of fun
um
i'm probably the one that started off my
run with john cena and john laurinitis
and all that stuff that was one of the
memorable ones for sure but
um
like i said there's there's been so many
opportunities
that's one of the things i try to
express to some of the younger talent
now it's you know versatility is not a
bad thing to have to have a long career
now i i've not to this point ever done
this before i try and keep it a little
professional but i have an action figure
here i want to show you all right and it
is probably the most ridiculous thing
i've ever seen so uh we got we got the
old the giant here but we've got a tiny
rey mysterio this dude's got this i know
go go gadget neck so that i guess you
can choke him mercilessly have you ever
seen this thing before that there's two
action figures in my career that i have
talked about that i thought were bad
ideas
that's one of them
because that came in the package and rey
mysterio who's one of the greatest
luchadors out of mexico ever who
innovated
uh luchador wrestling in america he came
as a side piece like a chair
or like a trash can it's like buy this
giant action figure and oh you also get
this little guy in chokeslam like i
thought and i went to ray right away i
said dude i had nothing to do with this
please don't think this is my idea and
you know ray is the consummate gentleman
he was cool and he was like hey long as
i'm getting the percentage i don't care
you know i mean ray really understood it
like me i felt horrible like oh my god
why would you
do that to another competitor the whole
purpose of action figures is to
to highlight a figure to you know
that kind of a thing and uh the other
one was the action figure with the red
button on the ribs
when you press the red button it would
vibrate like an electric toothbrush
and i'm like what why is it doing this
oh you're shaking because you're angry i
said no man this is this is not a good
idea this is
this this is not a good idea but you
know
they went out there got to be a few
blunders for all the heads yeah well
let's hope so let's hope so but those
are iconic pieces now but yeah that's i
actually have that set that you have
there i have in the box in my in my
storage unit amazing i have that one i
want to leave you with the last words if
it's gen zeroes or anything else you
want to let the people know about please
yeah well definitely we have some new
stuff coming out in june and uh if the
fans for science fiction fantasy fan you
definitely want to jump on board and
check out gen zeros uh i believe you can
go to gen zero zero's the website check
everything out there and um our first
episode
actually dropped the phone when we hit
the menu rolodex here i think may 18th
our first episode drops so it's uh if
you go to gen zeroes
you can sign out be a part of the
community catch the exclusive content
and be a part of that community and i
just gotta tell you as a science fiction
fantasy fan
who's probably
gone through about four 000 books in the
past 12 years because i do a lot of
audio books
so it's ridiculous um
this has an incredible story arc
incredible things happening so this is a
great series and i'm proud to be a part
of it
you